little Melvin's that their data Wow it's
delightful we all know what news is but
do you know what's never news when
someone in the news tells you the truth
about the news and the media everywhere
is mostly liberal but in this country
eighty-five percent of journalists are
registered Democrats so that's just a
fact right there's one Fox and there's
many many many more organizations on the
left but the problem is that the weight
of all of these organizations on one
side of the political spectrum when you
turn on your computer or you walk past
the TV if they're all saying the same
thing the weight of that convinces you
that it's true you don't question it
because everyone is saying it I didn't
even notice that there was a bias in the
media period one story after another or
here it's and it's all based on one
anonymous administration official a
former administration official right I
mean that's just that's not chosen death
I could listen to that for hours for us
this is an obvious truth yet the voice
of the hive is so pervasive it goes
unheard except we just heard her loud
and clear you already know what the
media is thinking ofnc is gonna eat this
stuff up you're right so what because
whenever the Emperor's whenever the
Emperor's New Clothes are exposed don't
expect the Emperor to tell you about it
the conformist media will sweep this
under a rug so it's up to us to burn
that rug even it's on if it's on top of
Chuck Todd's head for decades mainstream
media defended their bias saying they
aren't liberally biased just truth
biased and of course the truth is always
liberal which is funny because we've
lost count of how many times the media
has been dead wrong on so many things
from defending terrible institutions to
reanimating bad ideas the only reason
the only reason they never get called
out is because they run the calling out
business and so the ideas they love born
from teachers lounges and safe spaces
continue to harm us and there's no speed
bump in sight so forgive us if we find
Logan refreshing she told you what you
know already the media is about conflict
so there can only be two sides the
consensus um
them and the marginalized you and all
those ad dollars which come which back
the consensus that keep rolling in the
profit model for the news division isn't
news its division which is why in news
there is no nuance when it's
embarrassing there's not even news it's
either their side or the downside
alright Dana I think she should be hired
by Fox immediately what is it you she
got the job by the way bad news wand
because she actually says that she this
is that she's realizing this and you
can't just dismiss her outright for
saying that she's like now she's part of
the alright one your question before I
yell at one she is the Jettas Generation
X's Bernie Goldberg ah so in 2001
bernard goldberg wrote a book called
bias right yeah just left CBS news and
what happened three years later after he
published it the dan Rather was piece
which is what trying to take down george
w bush so that he with the fake
documents about the yeah military
service so she left CBS in 2018 and
she's free much like like bernie
goldberg became free and it was like the
scales drop from your eyes and then you
can you can see it and you can say
whatever you want besides she did one of
the best 60 Minutes reports is not about
politics at all she followed around this
couple that focused on lions in south
africa it was amazing yeah maybe
botswana mmm-hmm but it was amazing
interesting I don't think Bernie would
ever wear that dress maybe not baby yeah
but can I just say the reason why she
didn't realize that there was bias is
because she was out there doing real
reporting so the biggest criticism of
her today is that some people are
writing about this interview which was
done by Mike Ritland who's a former Navy
SEAL who served in Afghanistan and I
believe Iraq as well he runs the podcast
called Mike drop she talked about all
these things she was doing she's a woman
in her 20s single went into Afghanistan
alone at the time that 95 percent in the
country was was controlled by the
Taliban
hanging women in the soccer stadium and
she was going in to do some real
reporting she lived in Iraq for five
years attack she was cleaning blood off
of the equipment when her fellow
journalists were killed she was raped in
Egypt and yet these journalists and the
media critics are all criticizing her
for calling out and telling the truth
when she is exactly what they claim to
be the one running into the fire like
the fire fighter the one actually
looking for the truth the one doing the
job and being on the front lines
literally for an entire career so I
listened to the entire thing
it's three-hour podcast I wish it would
an end her story she's getting a lot of
attention for the media bias comments
but the story she tells about
Afghanistan and Africa and war coverage
are incredible I really like subscribe
to Mike drop today on your
recommendation there you go 2g there are
a lot of journalists who go into the war
zones and who are often treated as oh
just liberal media but guess they're in
war zones on a daily right they were
there tonight and the idea that she puts
her Oh sources just horse dinners how
ridiculous but sources are so important
for any work about oh well you can only
get the truth on certain conservative
outlets but what about it's not just Fox
what about the Wall Street Journal what
about Drudge oh my goodness all number
one despite whatever she has both sides
of the story lots of niche journalism
but she says oh you're not defending
tonight honestly did you want to hear
what she says about Trump and then yeah
this is she's talking about the coverage
of Trump all the coverage on Trump all
the time is negative the former
executive editor of the New York Times
has a book coming out Jill Abramson and
she says we would do I don't know dozens
of stories about Trump every single day
and every single one of them was
negative she said we have become the
anti-trump paper of record well that's
not a job that's a political position
that means we've become political
activists in a sense and some could
argue propagandists right and there's
some merit to that I don't think there's
any untruth isola truth but I think the
interesting thing about this that
because he is the current president I
think people forget ever Republican goes
through yeah sure I just think that
people hate him so much when it comes to
the media that is so out and open now
and quite frankly I don't think the
media really understands that they're
picking a side right now I think they're
so blinded by their own disgust of the
president and their own bias that they
don't realize that that they're peeking
aside one last thing I think people
criticize Fox a lot but there is a clear
line at Fox News division and opinion
wrap and in that line it's open they
tell you exactly what they're gonna do
and I think that's unfair for people to
compare us to the other network and say
oh the opinion people aren't doing hard
news with their opinion
CNN I cannot find where the line is half
the toast none watch Don Lemon and Chris
Cuomo and you can't tell if it's Abbott
and Costello or straight news I don't
know I like Avenue Costello don't get me
wrong
Elmo and Don talk to you later